PROFESSOR: The most
frequently used ODE solver
in MATLAB and Simulink is ODE45.
It is based on method published
by British mathematicians JR
Dormand and PJ Prince in 1980.
The basic method is order five.
The error correction uses a
companion order four method.
The slope of tn is, first
same as last left over
from the previous
successful step.
Then there are five more slopes
from function values at 1/5 h,
3/10h, 4/5h, 8/9h and
then at tn plus 1.
These six slopes, linear
combinations of them,
are used to produce yn plus 1.
The function is evaluated
at tn plus 1 and yn plus 1
to get a seventh slope.
And then linear
combinations of these
are used to produce
the error estimate.
Again, if the error
estimate is less
than the specified
accuracy requirements
the step is successful.
And then that error estimate is
used to get the next step size.
If the error is too big,
the step is unsuccessful
and that error estimate
is used to get the step
size to do the step over again.
If we want to see the actual
coefficients that are used,
you can go into
the code for ODE45.
There's a table with
the coefficients.
Or you go to the Wikipedia page
for the Dormand-Prince Method
and there is the
same coefficients.
As an aside, here is an
interesting fact about higher
order Runge-Kutta methods.
Classical Runge-Kutta required
four function evaluations
per step to get order four.
Dormand-Prince requires six
function evaluations per step
to get order five.
You can't get order five with
just five function evaluations.
And then, if we were to try
and achieve higher order,
it would take even more
function evaluations per step.
Let's use ODE45 to
compute e to the t.
y prime is equal to y.
We can ask for
output by supplying
an argument called tspan.
Zero and steps of 0.1 to 1.
If we supply that as
the input argument
to solve this
differential equation
and get the output
at those points,
we get that back as the output.
And now here's the
approximations to the solution
to that differential
equation at those points.
If we plot it, here's the
solution at those points.
And to see how
accurate it is, we
see that we're actually getting
this result to nine digits.
ODE45 is very accurate.
Let's look at step size
choice on our problem
with near singularity,
is a quarter.
y0 is close to 16.
The differential equation is
y prime is 2(a-t) y squared.
We let ODE45 choose its own
step size by indicating we just
want to integrate from 0 to 1.
We capture the output
in t and y and plot it.
Now, here, there's a
lot of points here,
but this is misleading
because ODE45, by default,
is using the refine option.
It's only actually
evaluating the function
at every fourth
one of these points
and then using the interpolant
to fill in in between.
So we actually need a
little different plot here.
This plot shows a little
better what's going on.
The big dots are the
points that ODE45
chose to evaluate the
differential equation.
And the little dots are filled
in with the interpolant.
So the big dots are
every fourth point.
And the refine option says that
the big dots are too far apart
and we need to fill it
in with the interpolant.
And so this is the continuous
interpolant in action.
The big dots are more
closely concentrated
as we have to go
around the curve.
And then, as we get farther
away from the singularity
the step size increases.
So this shows the
high accuracy of ODE45
and the automatic step
size choice in action.
Here's an exercise.
Compare ODE23 and ODE45 by using
each of them to compute pi.
The integral 4 over 1 plus
t squared from 0 to 1 is pi.
You can express that as
a differential equation,
use each of the routines to
integrate that differential
equation and see how close
they get to computing pi.